thousands of people still out of work in
southern nevada people trying to choose
which bills to pay leaving many in need
of food
so organizations like three square and
project for humanity say as we head into
the holidays
the need is only going to grow eight
news now reporter sally jaramillo tells
us what these organizations are doing
now
to help fight hunger in the valley so
ever since carpet hit
the pandemic definitely put a damper on
food insecurities that one i sent you
with the 11 pallets
shawna gonzalez the ceo and founder of
project for humanity says
food insecurities have increased in the
valley about 73 percent here in the
valley
40 of that being children homeless
children
gonzalez says they started to see an
increase in june when thousands started
losing their jobs
the need increased especially for
seniors and veterans
lisa segler with three square also
reports an increase in people needing
help
seniors in our valley right now are
experiencing
some serious challenges even pre-coveted
we know that the cause of housing the
lack of affordable housing here in
southern nevada
really poses an issue that's why both
three square and project for humanity
are stepping in
to help it's called golden groceries and
it's a supplemental grocery program
for those that are 60 and better so it
offers lean protein whole grains and
fresh produce
and it's a client choice model which is
something that we're very proud of we're
distributing 6 000 boxes this week going
out to seniors veterans and families
these boxes have
been vamped up um they have milk they
have eggs cheese cottage cheese
they'll have a cooked type of meat
they'll also have produce and apples
oranges
gonzalez says she doesn't see things
improving especially with the holidays
approaching
we cannot conquer hunger without
everybody sadly
8 news now sally thank you for that
still ahead on 8 news now the